i cannot change yesterday's newspaper
i'm not gonna let it burn me down
if we're not fit and healthy we're not
gonna be able to achieve anything so
um you know so you know i will swim
around the island
uh every day whatever the thing is that
makes you feel like you can come alive
that gives you that boldness and
confidence
plan it with intention every single day
wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
i believe a life hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn some of the
routines of
billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one let go of negativity with john paul
de jouria
anyone that you want to let's say uh uh
go against anybody you don't like
anybody that's as pleased as you anybody
you want revenge for anybody that you
hate anything you remember that someone
did bad to you
let it go forgive them
you don't have to say it out loud you
can say to yourself i forgive you
people you really really hate it's
amazing what happens
amazing something lifts off your
shoulder
and the negative isn't as strong as it
was before
this is an amazing thing that cost
absolutely nothing i cannot change
yesterday's newspaper
i'm not gonna let it burn me down
because by being in my subconscious mind
everything around me looks bleaker
because i had this bad stuff
happen to me before that i want a
revenge or that i hate it's still
in that subconscious mind get it out of
there
get it out there by saying i forgive you
no matter how bad they work
i forgive you no matter how much revenge
you want i forgive you no matter how
just it is or injustice i forgive you
it lifts the burden off you so when
these little things start happening and
they're little things now
but they're actually gigantic to you now
in the future you would have gone
through it would have been
smaller but one way to make it smaller
now is get off your shoulder out of your
mind
all that disrespect all that hate all
that revenge all that jealousy
get them out of there forgive everybody
for just forgive them
and you'd be amazed within 24 hours
maybe for one hour
something is just lifted off your
shoulders this is one good direction to
start going into and it doesn't hurt any
to meditate
and if you don't know how to meditate
just sit there close your eyes sit
upright
close your eyes put your hands wherever
you want and just uh close your eyes and
just look at a white light in front of
you
if there isn't one in front of you mock
one up if different things enter your
mind
the thought that could enter your mind
is i am i am part of god
i am and then you can focus on something
and if you can do that for 20 minutes in
the morning
and 20 minutes at late afternoon or at
night
you'll be amazed at how freer your body
is and how less tense you are about the
problems we have today
rule number two keep up to date with
bill gates
charlie munger and warren buffett every
morning what do you reach for
uh well i read new york times wall
street journal
the economist is sort of my regular
weekly fair
he can give you last weeks by memory
no it's great it's great to have
something you read on a regular basis
and they do special sections
um charlie what do you read
well i agree with bill i think the best
one publication i read is the economist
which is interesting yeah well i read
that but i i read the local paper
i read the ft i read the wall street
journal i read the new york times and i
and i read usa today rule number three
work on your mindset with sarah blakely
i sold fax machines door-to-door for
seven years
after graduating from college and i
you know for 20 years spanx is going to
be 20 i started it in the year 2000
and the sound bite in the media has been
sarah cut the feet out of pantyhose and
solved an undergarment issue and
you know now spanx is here and and while
that is true there was so much more
about
the behind the scenes of why this
happened and
people have asked me can i have 10
minutes 15 minutes of your time i want
to pick your brain on how spanx started
but the real answer is it started way
before i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose
and it it it started when i was much
younger and
i had a series of kind of tragic events
happen to me when i was in high school
and it led me to uh wayne dyer who is a
motivational
inspirational speaker he passed away
about two years ago
but i got exposed to him and i
listened to his cassette tapes over and
over and over again
to the point that i had his one series
called how to be a no limit person
memorized all 10 cassette tapes front
and back
and try living with that
well yeah that's funny because in high
school no one wanted to get stuck in my
car like after a party they're like
she's gonna make you listen to the [ __ ]
and so um but then you know i'd say i
said
i think i would take simple things like
i'm just going to do the laundry
tomorrow and she'd be like
do you know the ramifications of waiting
till tomorrow
so um but then fast forward you know i
think it was 10 to 15 years after high
school
that i ended up on the cover of forbes
and the texts i got in my phone were so
funny i mean literally all my friends
were like damn
should have listened to that [ __ ]
so but i'm a big believer in it i
learned early on about manifesting law
of attraction
not caring what other people think about
you which is a really big one for an
entrepreneur or
you know in life really and i'm a work
in progress on that there are times
where i do care and i check
myself and say you know let's let's work
on this but it's very freeing
to not care what other people think
you'll take more risks
um to not really focus on the outcome
and be so afraid to fail so
all of that is a big part of my journey
and and spanx for sure so i think
mindset is
i work on it daily rule number four have
a routine
with grant cardone
oh it's cold this morning you can beat
that freaking
thing up get up before it is
gives you a sense of i'm winning man i
hadn't done anything all i did was get
out of bed
[Music]
so dr you know i dress for success man i
got to grab my favorite watch out here
you know you got to have your favorite
watch
it's been probably 15 or 20 minutes a
day just responding
beat the sun up see that that encourages
him
and he encourages me and it just works
it works we all
we all help each other
[Music]
listen to the birds huh i hope you're
gonna have a great day today because i
am
i might have a great day if it's a bad
day i'm going to turn it into a great
day
because that's what i do remember some
of some of the days that have started
off bad for me have been the best days
of my life
you just got to hang in there you got to
stay in there you got to keep pushing
and shove it and say dude i'm going to
make a bad day a great
i'm going to flip this thing i'm going
to turn it on its head it's just a day
just today let me turn this thing turn
enough bad days into great days
you'll end up with a great life that's
it man nobody they don't teach that in
[Music]
school hey man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five keep
healthy with richard branson if we're
not fit and healthy we're not gonna be
able to achieve anything
so um you know so you know i will swim
around the island
uh every day or i'll you know go kite
surfing or i'll play tennis or i'll
you know i'll do something to make sure
that the body is healthy
and the endorphins are running and
and then i can throw myself into work um
and i suspect
um at least 50 of my time is sort of
setting up not-for-profit
uh organizations in the world to tackle
you know some of some of the bigger
problems of the world
um and you know the other 50 i suspect
is diving in and out on
you know some of our businesses around
the world you know maybe doing a bit of
firefighting when things are going wrong
or you know giving them a push you know
when things are going right
and rule number six the last one before
some very special bonus clips
is join the 5 am club with robin sharma
i wanted to give you some specific
insights on the value of rising before
the sun and
joining the 5 a.m club which is a
concept
i've been teaching to my billionaire
clients and
ceo clients and executives at companies
like starbucks
and fedex and ibm and nike and other
organizations that i've worked with
for over the past two decades with
tremendous success in terms of helping
them increase
their focus their energy their
productivity and their performance so
there's a reason why the visionary
founder of starbucks
howard schultz rises before the sun
there's a reason why
michelle obama rises very early there's
a reason why
tim cook who's leading apple gets up
before the dawn first of all the hours
between four and six are the time of
least distraction in this age of
dramatic
interruption number two the hours before
the sun rises is the period where
your brain is most available to
your primary creativity so while you're
sleeping your brain actually
washes itself but also it lets it go up
the residue of the previous day
while you are resting and while you are
recovering when you wake up
your thinking is fresh your creativity
is most pristine you are most
available to access
your gifts and your talents so those are
some of the reasons why i encourage you
to get a brill you might say robin well
i'm not an early riser i can't put mind
over mattress i can't win the battle of
the bed
grandma never got up early dad couldn't
get up early
i guess i'm not the kind of person who
can rise before the sun and what i would
suggest to you is simply this
[Music]
what science confirms in particular the
data
of university college london you do any
new habit practice it for 66 days
and you will arrive at the place of
automaticity in other words it'll be
easier to run the new habit than not to
66 days of rising at 5 a.m
will get you to a place where it's
easier to get up to 5 a.m
than not to get up at 5 00 a.m you'll
reach a place of automaticity
in my book the 5am club i say all change
is hard at first and it's messy in the
middle
and it's gorgeous at the end i'll repeat
that again because it's so important
all change is hard at first messy in the
middle and it's gorgeous at the end
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you i wake up in the
morning what you do and the first thing
i say is
thank you that's my first thing even
though i'm awake you know when my eyes
are really fully open
i i say thank you i can feel the
gratitude like
i'm still here i'm in a body thank you
so much i thank you for that
and then i go through the letting the
dogs out the whole
you know brushing your teeth and all
that stuff and then i
have either silence or prayer or
something that acknowledges
that i'm still here i do not reach for
that phone first that's your problem
meditation is the biggest gift that i
can give anyone
and i would say more than anything it is
whatever reason for success i've had
uh because it allows one
on back to the two u's i'll clarify
what i mean is that in your mind
there we think what do you want and the
reality is
when you look at the neuroscience and
psychology
that there are different parts of your
brain that want different things
and so in the simplest sense there is
the
logical part of the brain that you're
conscious of it's called the conscious
and you think you're being logical and
you want to make those decisions
and then there's the subliminal below
the limbic system
part of the brain which is the emotional
and it's not as conscious to you but it
has more of an influence
on you than really the logical one and
so they're not aligned
and so when you're experiencing that
pain or let's say the ego right there
were two
main things you got an ego barrier and a
blind spot barrier
if you can get past your ego barrier and
you get past your blind spot barrier
you can accomplish anything because
you'll also know that you don't have to
do everything to
you have to figure it out yourself you
can take in from other people
the different ways to approach things in
the best possible way
and so the realization that we all
are really struggling with ourselves and
to think
which are which is in control meditation
helps to deal with the alignment of
those two things
well i have four children under the age
of eight he turned to eight last week
so um time alone is even
more sacred and it's a time that i
absolutely need to carve out for myself
so one of the things that i did is i
found out when my best thinking time is
and it's in the car
so i live only five or six minutes from
the spanx headquarters
but i actually many times leave my house
an
hour before i need to be at work and go
on a fake commute
so my friends have laughed and called it
my fake commute but i realize that's
when my mind
wanders and and that's when my ideas
come to me and so i have to carve that
time out so i'm driving around with all
the other commuters and i'm like the
happy commuter because i
and i don't ever have an agenda of where
i'm going sometimes i'm in inman park
sometimes i end up in downtown
sometimes i'm in decatur i just drive
around and there must be something for
me about the activity of driving
and being able to think and just listen
to some background music that accesses a
certain part of my brain
and i read the other day that einstein
had all his best ideas
when he was shaving and so there must be
something about a rote activity that
you're doing that
allows you to at least at least for me
it's driving so that's one thing that i
would say that i do
so find out and identify when your best
think time is and and make sure you're
you're making that happen in your life
and i'm not talking about when you're
just going through your checklist of
everything you have to do
i'm talking about when does your mind
wander
and if you don't have enough time carved
out in your life
for your mind to wander you're not
accessing
the best part of yourself because
there's
there's a knowing inside of you and it's
when you're when you're in that space
not when you're watching tv and not you
know it's even more difficult now with
how much distractions we have
from ourselves i mean the balance of
work and play
is critical and i think a lot of people
don't get
that balance right you know i'm 63 years
old now so
uh critical to find time for yourself
uh get out there and keep fit and and i
find the best way of keeping fit is by
playing
i try to encourage our chief executives
worldwide to make sure that there's as
much flexibility in in the workplace
as possible we've set up something
called the b team which is examining
the way companies treat their staff and
trying to make suggestions to make the
dignity of work
better than it's been in the past
[Music]
if you're too close to a situation you
know like in an office
you get bogged down with the manuta if
you can step away from the situation
you can think about the bigger picture
and that's what i'm able to do on mecca
the most extraordinary people come to
necca the elders was conceived here on
necker with archbishop tutu with
president carter with kofi annan the
carbon wall room was conceived here an
organization that tries to work with
industry to try to
extract carbon out of the earth's
atmosphere you know sitting
in muhammad looking up at the stars at
night things like virgin galactic
so great place to think and a great
place to conceive ideas
[Music]
well we had a fantastic day it was a
sunday so it wasn't all work
so um a great way of capping off the day
watch the super bowl
with a cup of tea and uh and the chicken
to me you know exercise is like a you
know
probably the most influential thing in
my life
and you probably get that from a lot of
entrepreneurs right
successful entrepreneurs most of them
work out they have good physique
and you know you build your body first
and then you you build your mind your
mindset you know
and as you see results improvement your
muscles your body
your mind starts getting more confident
as well you know
and starts translating into business
life other areas communication
absolutely absolutely so that's been a
very big key for me and to this day i
still work out three times a week as we
get up you know listen we're always
scheduling everything else we're trying
to be on the train we're trying to be at
a meeting with time to be in a
conference call we're trying to go to
that dinner
with a bunch of clients that you don't
even really like to talk to anyway
they schedule every single they schedule
their health so they get up in the
morning they schedule their doctors they
schedule their family and then they go
ahead and schedule
the other things other people's
priorities but they schedule themselves
first and foremost
when you find yourself under stress and
anxiety things go wrong
you get disappointments things don't
work out as you hoped
you must feel a moment of anxiety a
moment of stress
how do you deal with that what happens
um
i can go out of the stress
i can at at any moment like there are
times when i
i feel the stress of the circumstances
um and then
i can at will
go out of that stress and just
see things in a different way and it
makes me feel
um almost like a ninja you know when the
in the ninja everything seems to come in
slow motion
you know and in the sense you could step
back and it's coming at me
at slow motion and i can deal with it in
in a way that makes me
feel more centered and in control you
guys are just getting started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there
okay probably in another city another
town i grew up in lake charles louisiana
no money
raised by a single mother i was in debt
at 25 years old
the first thing that i had to do in my
life was not
learn a new skill first thing i had to
do
to get my life moving in the right
direction was self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself and i could start
depending upon me
i had to show up every day with some
rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself
to do the right thing every day one of
the things that i started doing was
beating the sun up every morning
i'm going to beat that sun up every
morning so that i had the discipline and
the control
over my life so i knew hey
before that thing pops i'm going to pop
i'm going to get out of bed depend on
myself
get up at the same time every day and
for me that time regardless of where i
was
was beat that sun up no matter where i
am i'm gonna beat that thing up
so it gives me a sense of control over
my own life second thing
i had to start cleaning up my life and
my friends and my environment
when i was younger between 15 and 25 i
was doing
crazy stuff in my life wasting my
weekends i had the same weekends or for
the week
i was drinking fooling around with a
bunch of
bad things bad people making poor
choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places
quit using those things quit hanging out
with people that did not have ethics and
discipline in their life
that weren't committed to the same
things that i was i wanted to build
something in my life
i wanted to become someone and to do
that to become someone in the eyes of
the world
the first thing i had to do was become
someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do
every day to start the day kick start
your day
get going in your day to give you a
sense of
respect for yourself accomplishment for
yourself
look just beating that son up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment
that i did what i said said i was going
to do that i woke up when i said i would
wake up
and i start building respect for myself
start believing in myself
so that i can go out to the world and
maybe maybe
maybe today maybe today when i go into
this meeting
that i'm dressed for maybe they'll
believe in me as much as i believe in me
and that'll show up in a contract a deal
maybe even some money
beat the sun up if you practice any new
skill
for 66 days in a row through the power
of neuroplasticity which is the brain's
ability to adapt
then you are going to reach a point
called automaticity i want you to think
about that term
automaticity in other words after 66
days of practicing the 20 20 20 formula
and joining the 5 am club and running
the morning routine
you're going to get to a point where
it's automatic you're going to get to a
point where it's actually
easier to get up at 5 00 a.m than to
stay in
in bed i also want to offer you a brain
tattoo from the book to consider as you
wire in this learning protocol of
billionaires and highly creative people
professional athletes and industry
titans and it's this
all change is hard at first and it's
messy in the middle and it's beautiful
at the end
i'm going to repeat that again for you
because it's so important all change is
hard at first
if a new skill or a new routine
or a new habit was easy then it wouldn't
be valuable change
so anything that's valuable
is hard at first you know society says
live an easy life i suggest to you
that whether it's a great morning
routine whether it's building a great
business whether it's releasing your
master work to the world maybe it's a
great relationship
maybe it's a great interior life it
takes real effort
it takes the long game it takes focus it
takes
hard work it takes bravery but
the rewards are so much more glorious
than living an easy life okay
so and also remember the things you once
found difficult
you now find easy little kids for
example find
walking early on difficult or learning a
new nursery
rhyme or learning how to read or
learning how to build relationships at
first there's not a lot of
facility and fluency with those skills
because every skill is difficult at
first until you
practice it and then train until you get
to a place
where you master it and so your morning
routine is going to be challenging at
first but
with daily training and practicing the
20
20 20 formula i promise you you're going
to get to a point
of mastery and then the payoffs are
extraordinary
your creativity will soar your
productivity will maximize
you will actually attract more
prosperity into your life because the
marketplace rewards
true creativity and productivity you're
going to feel so much more happier
in your day you're going to find that
sense of peacefulness so it's almost
like
you go through a life with a greater
level of grace
and ease you know the way you start your
day determines the way your day is going
to unfold
you must come up with a morning routine
that you do every single morning
or at least more mornings than not that
puts you
in control of yourself and in control of
your day
this is what i do and i cannot explain
the power that i get from starting my
day off
and being bigger than my excuses and
being in control
first and foremost wake up on time when
that alarm goes off
get your butt out of bed five four three
two one go
why is that important for persistence
the reason why
is because the first decision that
you're making of the day
is to actually get up and get moving
that means
you are persistently bigger
than your excuses you are persistently
bigger than feeling lazy and you are
persistently beating the feelings that
typically stop you
the second thing that i want you to do
before you look at your email
before you answer your phone before you
start
surfing vox and vice and buzzfeed and
you know
team stream and checking out the sales
on zappos and looking at your facebook
news feed before you pick up the
phone please please please figure out
your two priorities for the day
these are the things that matter to you
whether it's saving money and
and making sure you're focused on that
or showing up at work
and being a contributor or whether it's
changing
how you treat your spouse or your kids
or the person that you're with
or getting to the gym because you said
you would
whatever it is that your two priorities
are
put them in your head before you pick up
the phone why
the reason why is because of persistence
the reason why
is because i want you to have a good day
do you know what makes for a bad day
what makes for a bad day is snoozing
starting your day off late starting your
day off tired
starting your day off by mainlining
everybody else's news feed
on social media and looking at everybody
else's life and
and saying to yourself oh my god they're
on vacation or gosh they look so great
or
their friends are so fancy or my gosh
they've got some money
you start off your day looking at that
you're never gonna have a good day
you gotta start off your day by getting
up on time figuring out your priorities
and then getting to work on them do not
pick up your phone until you have done
those two things
i think the single biggest reason why
people have bad days
is because they start them off by
looking around at everybody else and
seeing what they're doing
instead of having the focus and the
discipline
to actually start your day off with you
in control and with your priorities
front and center
so you want a bonus round exercise every
day that's right
get up on time figure out your
priorities and exercise
you do those three things you'll be
kicking ass every single day
what is the thing that makes you sore
every day what's the thing that makes
you feel alive
bold confident what is that and put it
into your morning routine
at some point in your life you felt bold
you felt unstoppable you felt confident
it's happened to everybody
the problem is you don't feel that way
consistently every day
you go through these bursts these
moments of man i could do such amazing
things
but then the next day you wake up and
you're a different person you're back to
the
i don't know if i can do it i don't know
who am i to go do this crazy thing
that's the problem so whatever the thing
is that makes you feel like you can come
alive that gives you that boldness and
confidence
plan it with intention every single day
into your morning routine
for me what i do is i record a message
on my phone to to instagram to my
stories to
i put it to linkedin and twitter right
now i'm putting it everywhere but i need
to make a message
so i think of somebody that i helped
yesterday i think of somebody who
commented on a video who i met in person
who i coached on my instagram live
somebody that i helped yesterday and
then i make a message
channeling that person i won't say the
person's name but
i have them in my head i need to remind
myself that the work that i do is
important
it's easy to get lost in numbers it's
it's hard to imagine that
two to three hundred thousand people
watched my videos yesterday that's
crazy it's a wild number right it's wild
it's hard to
like what does that even mean i don't
know i'm just sitting here talking to a
camera
in my office and two to three hundred
thousand people are watching my videos
it's crazy
i need to think down to the actual
person i need to think about an
individual that this
matters to somebody that the work i do
really means something to them
and then i need to record a message and
share it that helps me soar and i do it
every day
what is the thing for you what makes you
sore maybe it's watching the 254 series
that i put up
every day maybe it's watching the
espresso videos like this that i
put up every day and some people every
day this is part of the morning routine
is watch an espresso video and i'm
humbled to be a part of your morning
routine
for other people it might be meditating
that might be watching a video it might
be reading a book and listening to a
podcast i don't care what the thing is
but you have felt bold unstoppable and
confident at some point in your life
what led you to feeling that way and
then demanded of yourself every day
by putting it into your morning routine
[Music]
if you want even more advice and
routines from billionaires check out the
video
right there next to me i think you'll
love them continue to believe
and i'll see you there there are times
when i feel the stress of the
circumstances
and then i can at will
go out of that stress first thing i had
to do to get my life